fast get off the car no can do mr. Nash  I'm so bad why you come see me after  school for detention yeah do you have it  once supervirus no computer can resist  and I have my Prudhoe burn she's crazy  but I'd tap that  the other bad kids aren't here yet oh  there are no such thing as bad kids max  why are you all on the go Oh wonderful  your old friends [ __ ] this will be safe  for us off especially after that  horrible event that happened this school  really is cursed  well it's having us in here  if you would like to survive the next  few minutes it's very care bill us this  place is Kerber accident  oh damn roaches  we're trapped to take care of business  as we speak  how's it just plan B  I know who she is I want a piece of that  action now there's something you don't  see every day  you will never leave this school alive  watch me [ __ ]  you act like it's a miracle that they  don't kill each other  you